♪ (SYMPHONY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Hello. I'm Chukwudi Iwuji,
and I will be playing the role
of Clemson Murn in
the HBO Max series, Peacemaker.
I made a vow to have peace
at any cost,
no matter how many men,
women, and children
I need to kill to get it.
Good. 'Cause right now,
the world needs a son of a bitch
and you're the only one I got.
Today, I'll be preparing
for the role
with dramatic readings of
some of the most iconic scenes
in DC Comics' history.
"Alfred hates it...
...but he loves the coffee."
"...Black Lantern."
"This takes hard work!"
"...'You're done!'"
"...I had a bladder spasm."
"You're saying
you wet your pants?"
(SNORTS)
(LAUGHS)
(MIMICS ELECTRICAL DISCHARGE)
(WHIMPERS)
"Every job I pull
will involve pennies.
My crime symbol
will be pennies!"
This is the most fun
I've ever had.
This has been dramatic
comic book readings
with Chukwudi Iwuji.
Thank you for joining me
for this exercise
in the art of acting,
and I beseech you,
don't miss my turn
as Clemson Murn on Peacemaker.
Any questions?
Only on HBO Max.